la population entend ce discours que les
ehpad ne seront par confiner alors que
nous familles concernées familles
impliquées on sait ce qui se passe sur
le terrain et on hurle notre colère
[Musique]
ce protocole comme tous les précédents
ne sont que des recommandations
donc chaque directeur est libre de les
assouplir où les resserrer le directeur
a ce pouvoir qui est un pouvoir de
police sur les résidents il a ce pouvoir
qui fait qu'il peut faire ce qu'ils
veulent tout seul comme d'avoir gaignon
demande au directeur nous consulter les
résidents et les familles vous vous
doutez bien quand une majorité des pâtes
ce n'est pas fait
[Musique]
le confinement est devenu de prétexte à
tous est venue la réponse à tout
certaines familles n'ont pas pu ou pas
voulu se rebeller entre guillemets parce
qu'elle avait peur des représailles sur
leurs parents il ya un problème dans les
pages au lieu que les familles viennent
voir ce qui se passe on ce tacle les
manquements ou de la maltraitance et
barbe ou fermer les portes tout se passe
en vasco les ehpad qui on ne veulent pas
de problème enferme les résidents et met
les familles à la porte
[Musique]
les résidents ont massivement joué le
jeu du vaccin pour retrouver la liberté
il est totalement intolérable de voir
des personnes vaccinées trois doses être
recompilé alors que dans la population
certaines personnes ne sont pas vaccinés
[Musique]
nous n'avons jamais le nombre de morts
précis par glissement dans les portes se
sont ouvertes après les deux les deux
premières vagues les résidants étaient
des morts-vivants vous rendriez ceux qui
pouvaient encore un petit peu parle elle
parlait plus tout le monde était triste
des résidents avec les yeux perdus dans
le vague ça c'est plus possible nos
parents sont au bout du rouleau ils sont
déjà survivants des vagues précédentes
et les familles sont aussi abu désespéré
est très en colère
[Musique]